- Hello, welcome to SaturDIARY.
(whip lashing, bottle bouncing)
Yes, this is happening
because I just got back
from watching Krampus, whew whew whew.
If you don't know, SaturDIARY's
a look back at my week
in blog form, so let's look
back on some of the things
that happened this week.
(upbeat jazz music)
Oh ho, yeah, what a face.
This is what my face looks like at 6:26 AM
after I got back from New York
seven hours ago.
We are headed to the set of Dirty Thirty,
which I am so excited for
because we've all been off
for nine days, we had a nine day break
in the middle of shooting, so (laughs)
if there's some continuity errors in
the bloatedness of our
faces, you know why.
We had nine days off and Thanksgiving.
So let's head back to
set and see everyone.
(screaming excitedly)
Set, set, look, everyone's working.
Tom's back with his mustache.
Kevin, I heard you got really
drunk at the Clippers game.
(laughs)
So this is where we are shooting today.
The glamour, the glamour, the glamour.
(upbeat jazz music)
- Don't crime, kids.
- [Grace] Don't crime?
- Don't crime.
♫ Don't crime for me, Argentina ♫
- [Hannah] Oh no, now we're done.
- Hello FriDIARY, happy Thursday.
It is Thursday, I've done
a pretty (cymbal crash) job
of vlogging this week.
I will tell you flat
out, you heard it from
the horse's mouth, me, nay.
I've also done a great job at
losing my mind, apparently.
I am headed, you're all gonna laugh at me,
I'm headed to the (cymbal
crash) dentist again (laughs).
No, not because my temporary
crown has come out,
but because I have two
other cavities that've never
gotten filled and then I'm
going to the office to meet
with Diane to count all of these.
Can you see boxes of things?
These are, if any of you
remember from like two years ago
at VidCon, tote bags
that I designed that say
"Eat (cymbal crash)" on them
and these are the leftover ones
that never got sold, so
these are getting upcycled
into tote bags for the giveaway of
Grace & Style: The Art of
Pretending You Have It,
my book that is available for pre-sale,
which you should go
pre-order, if you haven't yet.
I know we're all buying Christmas
gifts and that's a weird
thing to ask you to do, to
pre-order something that doesn't
come out til February, but,
(sighs) waiting makes
the heart grow fonder?
No, waiting makes the brain grow angrier.
I have a lot more that I want
to talk to you guys about,
with the Style book, but I'll
make sure to do that after
half of my mouth is numb, so, until then.
(groans) Yowsas.
A dramatic improvement
in video quality and
a dramatic reduction of
facial quality.
Hey guys, it's Friday and I
realize that I didn't finish up
anything yesterday with
you about the dentist.
Everything's fine, turns
out I had four cavities
instead of two and they
filled all of them, hooray.
And today, I got invited to go
to this event for Vanity Fair
and Ralph Lauren, Ralph Loren, who knows.
Tomatoes, bruschetta.
And so, I thought since I
haven't vlogged very much
this week and because I have
a style guide coming out
that I would do a "Get Ready
with Me" type of time with you
as I anxiously prepare to
go to an event by myself
with fashion types, doesn't
that sound goddamned delightful?
I've already done the basics,
I have done some stress running
and some stress showering,
so now I'm going to
stress dry my hair, let's do it.
(upbeat jazz music)
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
This side, I could be a YouTuber
from 2006
and from this side, I could
be a soccer mom (laughs).
So my hair is dried and I put in
this get wow, this stuff.
It did (cymbal crash).
I never do videos like
this and I keep looking at
my goddamned face.
So, you have so much dust on your face.
It's very becoming.
It's becoming very annoying (laughs).
Okay, so I think I'm just
gonna start doing my makeup
and have a chat with
you guys and I thought
this would be appropriate
to do something like this
because of this.
This is an advanced, uncorrected proof,
not for sale version of Grace & Style,
my new style guide.
The book comes out February 2nd,
and I want you to pre-order
it, but I know you're buying
people a lot of holiday
gifts and all of that,
so it's okay if you don't, I
will just completely hold it
against you forever, but because
it comes out February 2nd,
I wanted to start doing some
more beauty-centric videos
on this channel, not that I'm
going to become a beauty guru
because I just can't, like
I've tried and I just, I can't.
And this is another attempt at me trying,
but also me trying the
only way I know how,
which is by pretending.
Let's just start putting
paint on the barn.
So what I've been doing a
lot lately is I use some
Laura Mercier tinted
moisturizer as kind of a
primer on my face, before
the other (cymbal crash)
goes on my face.
I guess I can talk to you
about some of the other things
that you can expect from the book,
because I haven't really
talked about it very much
and it's because there's
been so many other things
to talk about with you guys,
like DirtyThirtymovie.com
and the Australian No Filter
Tour that you guys should
all get tickets to, if
you live in Australia.
I want you guys to know
how excited I am about it
and I want you to know
more about what it is,
but I feel like I've been pretty vague.
It's a tongue-in-cheek style guide,
so it gives you guys
(ululating voice in throat).
That's the sound that beauty makes.
So the book is meant to
give you guys a look at my
beauty journey, on a personal level,
which, it starts out really
personally, and I did not
expect it to start out so
personally, but it just came out
of my brain and my hands and
onto paper and into a computer
and now into the book and
it's about my kind of personal
struggles and, you know,
highs and lows with beauty
and fashion and how I've
come to see it in my world
and how I've some to see the comedy in it,
which has helped me understand it more and
embrace it and celebrate it more,
but then there goes into
a lot of ridiculous tips
about fashion and beauty
and what certain things
might suggest about your
personality, if you wear them
or put them on your person.
There's also some advice
from my mom in there
that I think is really exciting
and it's genuine advice
about, you know, beauty,
self-esteem and that sort of thing.
(blows raspberry) I
haven't gotten very far,
I've talked too much, what am I doing,
oh, I put on some smashbox BB cream,
which I also use as a primer.
I basically, I love a lot
of foundation on my face
because my skin is really
sensitive to temperature
and embarrassment, so I get red a lot.
Ooh, this Clinique Beyond
Perfecting foundation
and concealer, Candy Johnson
recommended this in a video
of hers recently and so I
ordered it and I love it.
This is really fantastic,
full-coverage foundation
that I'm a big fan of.
I'm not a big fan of the applicator,
cause you gotta do like
this, yes look at that,
that, this is fashion.
Look at that there, great,
yes, very Ralph Lauren.
Maybe I should stop talking so much
and just get to doing the makeup.
Also, I have no idea
what I'm wearing tonight
because it is, um, quote
unquote, "cocktail attire."
To me, you know, when
I hear that something
is cocktail attire, I quote
the great Justin Bieber
and I'm all like, "what do you mean?"
Wow, oh wow, yes.
If you hate this, feel free to let me know
and I'll never do it again
until I forget how much
you hated it and I do it again.
Now I'm gonna do eyebrows,
oh, I got a new eyebrow thing.
Brow Define and Fill Maybelline duo thing.
Okay, how does this work?
I got a little spooly that I'm
gonna brush my eyebrows with.
Wow, you guys, wow.
My eyebrows look weird.
Ah, so it's got this
little tip that you do the
little strokes with and
then, give it to me,
oh and then you fill it in
with the little spongy side.
(upbeat jazz music)
So I've been going for
some strong eyebrows.
(upbeat jazz music)
How do beauty gurus do this?
This is really stressing me out,
to do my makeup on camera you guys.
Ooh, I like this, okay, eyebrows.
Fleeked-ish.
So let's start to do eyes
and heat up our hair thing.
Oh boy, you're back and
there's been progress-ish made.
I love this, I got this in
the danger zone of Sephora
that I call the danger zone,
it's the zone of all like
the mini sample and travel
sized things at the registers.
So Sephora, like eye shadow
palate for the holidays,
so they all have festive names like,
no, they don't have festive names.
They have names like Hot
Cocoa, Chantilly Lace,
Toasted Almond, Soft Cookie,
and then Midnight Swim.
I don't want to swim
at midnight in anything
that is this color.
So, I use like this shimmery
one and that plain one
but then I use, this is
one of my favorite palates.
This, Jo, oh, look how dirty,
Josie Maran, Jose Maran.
It's a palate called (laughs), yeah it is,
called Beautiful Nudes.
It's like really pretty
kind of pinky-browns
and goldish things and so I use those.
I think I'm gonna try Stag,
this Urban Decay eyeliner.
Alright, let's smudge
some eyeliner in there.
(upbeat jazz music)
Got some eyeliner on there.
Now, let's smudge it.
(upbeat jazz music)
You got smudged.
Cool, that seems like a thing.
Now let's put some mascara on.
Ahh yes, look at that.
The hand thing worked,
oh my god beauty gurus,
the hand thing worked.
The Better Than Sex mascara, Too Faced.
I had it upside down, thank
god, look at that, wow.
This is my favorite mascara
of all time forever.
It's sloppy and wet,
like sex, I've said that
in a video before and
the best part is if you
pre-order the new style
guide, Grace & Style:
The Art of Pretending You Have It,
and you go to
gracestylebook.com, you can enter
a sweepstakes in which you
could potentially win a
custom tote bag by me for
you with some of my favorite
beauty products in it and
this is one of them wa-woo!
I love this mascara.
It has a stupidly over-sexualized name,
but that is most beauty
products, I don't know why.
Here are some potential
names for beauty products
that didn't make the cut: Plan-B-eautiful,
Itchy, Regrettable, Garlic, Bulge,
whoa, kay, hey you, you should go,
that was the dog, I need to get new pants.
Swiffer Wet Jet.
Just in case, you know, those
are some potential names.
Whoa, hey buddy.
Um, okay, now let's put
some bronzer on, woo.
We're getting there and
then we're gonna do hair.
This takes so long to do,
especially with talking to
you guys, I mean, I love it.
Okay.
(upbeat jazz music)
Great, now we're gonna put some blush on.
Blush, yes, blush is the term.
Oh, but right now we're gonna do hair.
Let's do hair.
I started heating up, I
have this new curling wand
that everyone has, so I'm gonna
try and do some loose waves.
What do you call a slutty ocean?
Loose waves.
Did it, nailed it, I would
high-five myself, but you are hot.
(upbeat jazz music)
Okay, hair has been did did did did-ish.
Now comes the next wave
of stress, figuring out if
I even want to attempt false eyelashes.
They make me so nervous
because I don't trust myself.
You know what, let's try.
Actually, let's try.
Okay, glue, ow, so much glue.
So way too much glue (laughs).
(puffing breaths)
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Okay, oh glue, yes.
(puffing breaths)
Oh no, this one went bad.
Oh, this one went bad.
Oh, this is going so poor.
Nope, oh god, oh wrong.
Oh my god, Candy Johnson, how do you
(cymbal crash) do this?
Oh god, being a girl sucks so hard.
I'm gonna go pick out an outfit and
show you the final product.
Okay guys, I have to go,
I'm classically way later
than I should be, but
here's the final look.
Does that, hey, there, ahh yes,
makeup and things, hooray.
And then I'm wearing
a dress, from Top Shop
and shoes, also from Top Shop.
Everything's Top Shop.
Oh god, and (stammers).
I don't wanna go, but let's go.
Hello, and just like
that, I've made it home.
Um, this scene, yay, is here.
Uh, I survived the event.
I filmed nothing at it, because
it was a very casual event.
It was great, I met Olivia Wilde.
She is absolutely awesome
and everyone was really nice.
So hey, did it, this is
actually like, for me to go to
an event by myself makes me
feel like I did something.
I did something, I did it, I did it!
Okay, let's chill.
Ahh, so if it isn't blatantly
clear, you should pre-order
my book, Grace & Style: The
Art of Pretending You Have It
at gracestylebook.com
and enter the sweepstakes
and if you live in Australia,
there are still a few tickets
left for the No Filter Show Tours.
Tour, one tour, one tour, five shows.
I think two of them are
completely sold out,
there might be a third one sold out.
Get your tickets.
I don't know.
- [Voiceover] During the movie...
(people talking over each other)
- [Grace] This is some
post-Krampus discussion right now.
(people laughing)
- It's sampling.
- [Grace] Very exciting.
- [Voiceover] A lot of
discussion, mostly eating.